this is a production of Cornell
University
so the person who drew the luckiest
number of the day when you do number one
is you newly and new comes to us from
Incheon Korea her mentors were Michael
gore and Elodie Gaddafi and her post
graduation plans are waiting for the
admittance decisions to a graduate
program in Europe so we wish your love
with that first the title alfred seminar
today is polymorphic inversion in brass
opinion hi my presentation today is
about polymorphic inversion in breast
Canopus L of plenteous I'll be talking
about the evolutionary process of brass
cannabis a process of Brasco species and
what is pulling for conversion and what
are the strategies that we use to detect
polio-free conversion and how we process
the data to find in Furman ifs that
could help confirming the prolific
conversion and breast connect with
species and results and conclusions this
is the triangle of view which represents
the relationship of six different braska
species there are three ancestral
species respectively bresca [ __ ]
Rustica chemistry and rapa and Brassica
oleracea that has a 1 sub genome B a and
C with a chromosome number 8 10 and 9
respectively and there are three species
that were created due to intercept
interspecific hydrogen between two
ancestral species for the purpose of
presentation today I'll be focusing on
interspecific high radiation of rasa
cannabis so the evolution of Braska
deathless species were created by
Brassica oleracea which is scale and
Brassica Rapa and campus chemistry such
as bok choy they went through
interspecific hydrate hug radiation to
create breast Kannapolis commonly known
as canola so dr. LOD cassabi was
working on Dreskin other species and she
found the putative
pulling risky inversions polymorphic
inversion prevents Mulla bus route and
pairing during meiosis which do let do
go through recommendation between
inversion heterozygotes but products are
not recovered that it's a problematic
for dog breeders and the farmers who are
looking for better or higher yielding
crops and the frequency distribution of
chloroplast haplotypes of Brassica napus
and it's a sister like textile lineage
have strongly suggested that
Ratheon apis have fully phyletic origin
with the initial hydration eventually
leading to synthesis of Brassica napus
multiple times and probably involving
different maternal ancestors each one is
showing the ancestral lineage and h2 the
richness represented in blue is showing
dr character of the lineage so for
studying of pulling American version of
Brassica napus we gathered 16 samples
worldwide and we mapped the chromosome
map of Brassica napus there are two
standout two sub genomes in Brassica
napus with total of 19 chromosomes blue
is showing chromosome 8 and orange
showing chromosome C I studied
specifically chromosome c2 which has a
large Khalifa conversion and these were
based on this chromosome map we gathered
primers data from for studying this
putative pulmonary condition the goal of
this project was first GBS genotyping by
sequencing and WGS whole genome
sequencing were pre sequence by dr. le
digas avi and she found the putative
reversion rest Napa samples so we used
on
Sanger sequencing method in other
bioinformatic pipelines to validate
whether the potatoes in version that she
found were real or not these artists
steps that we use to determine the
polymorphic conversion double-hole
genotyping whole genome sequencing which
is sequencing the whole genome and
genotyping by sequencing which is
looking for to on single nucleotide
polymorphism and the genome we requested
by doctor políticas avi and we use
sniffs that were from WG s and GBS to
compare those compare to confirm
polio-free conversion and also use a
singer sequencing method to validate for
fully Morpha conversion so there were 60
samples worldwide and we harvested those
leaves and using five different primers
because there were snips were within all
different locations and there were large
that was hard to flank all the students
with one primer after DNA with this
extraction we went through PCR to
amplify a gene of interest and do DNA
purification to get rid of contaminants
and run through singer sequencing which
screens the identification of sequence
variation we used on different
bioinformatics pipelines from linux
operating systems to Python and Excel
for confirming if the pulley metric
conversion is real so for Sanger
sequencing we looked at the pattern
where one is showing the fixed alleles
across orientation which does not give
in fermented or unique information and
to 3 & 5 as alleles there are variable
of course orientation and we can see
that there are some inversions within
the within the pattern but however if we
look at up there are their alleles they
are just fixed so which does not give
unformatted snips
however we look at number 4
our our sniffs there are different in to
orientation but they are fixed which
could be informative the sister result
from one of the data we got from Sanger
sequencing that our first letter as a
diagnostic of ancestral lineage
respectively GMT and second letter is a
diagnostic of drive care drive lineage
aid T and G C so for after Sanger
sequencing we use the bioinformatics
pipeline to look for sniffs that are in
just whole genome sequencing and
genotyping by sequencing and snips that
are shared by both and there were around
23,000 for WGS and thousand for GBS and
545 for shared by both sequencing method
for the summary of the comparisons from
WGS and GBS they were sorted according
to subset of differences similarities
based on ancestral lineage and drives
lineage and the proportion of snips were
calculated that were no longer fixed or
before opposite alleles based on whole
genome sequencing there were a total of
112 snips fixed across boxes alleles
accorded to GBS however there are only
hundred six nips in GG s and and also
there were a total of 112 sniffs that
were fixed in two groups according to
GPS but out of 112 there were six out of
65 sniffs there were 16 snips that were
not in fermented due to low six-car
power of GBS which can be seen in the
orange column that doesn't have any
number of alleles and there were a total
of 106 snips that I'm 60% were found to
have both alleles and 80 percent help
showing nidal abilities that finally
this data showed that
genotype detected by GBS we're comforted
by whole genome sequencing which the
inversion might be real for a future
study by own a no techniques will be
used to map genome of selected Brassica
samples and by nano techniques are the
technique that do the whole genome
restriction map to validate assembly or
an identify structural variation and
based on the results from this proud
nano technique we might be able to
evaluate whether the inversion is in the
whole genome level or not for conclusion
so the potato reversion inversion was
detected by GPS and that was confirmed
by hos double OGS and it was again
validated using Sanger sequencing and I
also learned in fermented and form
important bioinformatics
technique that could be useful for
modern and on 21st century breeding
program thanks for dr. gore and dr. LOD
fasabi and Nicolas Kazmir for helping me
for doing research and thanks for dr.
Scanlan and dr. smart for allowing me to
present in here thank you because if
there is a
inversion in the species as I said
before there might be a recombination
but the products are not recovered which
means it won't create the species that
you are looking for so this problem for
the fritters where I'm trying to make a
new and better go
I am not sure about that I don't think
we did like multiple image studies other
questions for you in June this has been
a production of Cornell University on
the web at Cornell edu